bien joué ariane est la fusée a mis sur
orbite cette nuit le premier satellite
français de télédiffusion directe qui
devrait vous permettre comme son nom
l'indiqué de recevoir des émissions en
direct grâce à une antenne parabolique
dans 24 jours il aura à trouver sa
position définitive je parle du
satellite quelque part au dessus de
l'atlantique à trente six mille
kilomètres d'altitude
ça fait dix ans que l'on attendait cet
instant et hier soir on a vu décidé
d'oublier les querelles les polémiques
les remises en cause que ces sites
satellites
il fallait que cela marche ça a marché
l'ambiance et les réactions avec patrick
esther cours ou pc jupiter 3h17 ce matin
les techniciens chargés du lancement
d'ariane sont relativement détendus
trois deux un feu en fait ce n'est pas
véritablement un échec de la fusée que
l'on redoute les amener vente ul
problème sur le satellite tdf 1 à paris
malgré l'heure tardive dans une salle
des champs elysées l'applaudît aux
événements majeurs du vol en présence
d'un impressionnant parterre de
ministres
les applaudissements qui redouble avec
l'annoncé de la séparation réussi du
satellite et de la fusée mais les
responsables techniques réservent encore
leur sentiment ils savent qu'il faut
attendre quelques minutes avant de se
réjouir
lors du lancement de tv sat le frère
jumeau tdf 1 les deux panneaux solaires
ne s'était pas ouvert ce soir évidemment
on était un peu plus tendu et on a pu
réellement applaudir comme vous l'avez
remarqué que lorsque les deux ados se
sont dépliés
douar effectivement on est satisfait de
ses performances mais on n'est pas
complètement heureux parce que comme
vous le savez bien de ce satellite avant
d'être pleinement fonctionnel doit
encore subir des épreuves pendant
environ trois semaines
un premier succès technique en tout cas
qui permet d'envisager plus sereinement
l'avenir de tdf 1 un programme qui a été
particulièrement critiqué ces dix
dernières années
chaque fois qu'on fait les choses
nouvelles surtout quand il ya des
difficultés il y en a toujours dans ses
grands programmes technologiques
on est forcément l'objet de critiques
c'est normal d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y
en avait qui étaient fondées d'autres
qui étaient totalement infondées je
crois qu'il y aura un grand lot de
fausses idées qui se seront envolés ce
soir avec ariane tf1 devrait transmettre
ses premières images de télévision dès
janvier 1989